meine Lieben visualpolitik Zuschauer
wenn wir von der russischen Armee in der
Ukraine sprechen dann geht es eigentlich
um einen Drachen mit drei Köpfen gut
aber wer oder was sind diese drei Köpfen
und zum einen haben wir da die reguläre
Armee über die wir hier auf
visualproduktion einige Male ausführlich
berichtet haben zum anderen ist da der
tschetschenische Anführer Ramsan
kardiolov über dessen undurchsichtiges
Spiel wie hier auf visualpolitik auch
schon gesprochen haben auch wenn sich
seine Leute in der Ukraine nicht mehr so
groß blicken lassen er bleibt ein
Kriegstreiber mit ziemlich massive
Präsenz in den sozialen Medien
aber es gibt da noch einen dritten Kopf
der in der letzten Zeit ziemlich viel
Schlagzeilen gemacht hat und auf den wir
uns in unserem heutigen Video
konzentrieren wollen
der Inhaber und Kommandeur der
wagnergruppe der wichtigsten Söldner
Firma in Russland wer mag kann ihn zu
den berühmt berüchtigten russischen
zählen obwohl er unter diesen von der
Finanzkraft wohl eher im zweiten oder
dritten Glied steht und im Gegensatz zu
den Silo Wiki also den Falken der
russischen polizistenszene über die wir
auch schon einige Male gesprochen haben
und bei denen es sich zumeist
umgebildete Menschen mit Technokraten
Profil handelt hat pregorian einen ganz
anderen ziemlich finsteren background
aber dazu später mehr als wir mit der
Produktion dieses Videos begann hatte
aus dem Umland er hat und kämpften Stadt
bachmut gerade folgende Videobotschaft
an Präsident selenski gerichtet
ganz schön selbstsicherer
präsentiert sich wie ein Heerführer der
ein unterliegenden Gegner zum Aufgeben
auffordert aber bei diesem Gegner
handelt es sich nicht um ein paar
Aufständische in Syrien oder Warlords in
Afrika sondern um die mittlerweile durch
den Westen hochgerüsteten und
erstklassig ausgebildeten Streitkräfte
eines großen europäischen Landes um ein
stolzes Herz das ist immerhin geschafft
hat die angeblich zweitstärkste Armee
der Welt aufzuhalten und erheblich
zurück zu drängen war brigosch in Sieges
Gewissheit also wirklich angebracht nun
als ich die Arbeiten an diesem Video
abschlossen sah die Lage schon wieder
etwas anders aus
der Feind hat eine Gruppierung von
bereits mehr als 80.000 Mann um bachmut
konzentriert die Streitkräfte der
Ukraine könnten zusätzlich zu den
Militäroperationen artemos versuchen den
ersten Schlag in Richtung zu führen sie
werden versuchen belgora zu erreichen
am 23.03.2023
die Schlacht umbachmut hat die
ukrainische Armee heute bereits
praktisch vernichtet und leider auch die
wagnergruppe schwer beschädigt wenn
Wagner untergeht wird es die
Streitkräfte der Ukraine und die
Außerirdischen Söldner mit sich reißen
und der so den russischen Streitkräften
ermöglichen voranzuschreiten um die
Interessen des Landes zu schützen dann
wird unsere historische Mission erfüllt
sein jetzt gehen niedriger schön am
29.03.2023 Tross extremer mehrmonatige
Anstrengungen und hoher Verluste ist es
den Wagner sollte nicht gelungen ihr
Hauptziel die ukrainische Stadt bachmut
einzunehmen über die Gründe haben wir
bereits ausführlicher in unserem letzten
Video gesprochen und ich werde es euch
verlinken am Ende des heutigen Videos
wollen wir für euch aber trotzdem noch
als besonderes schmanker die spezielle
Wagner Taktik bei bachmut aus
militärischer Sicht auseinandernehmen
ihr werdet danach genau verstehen warum
sie nicht funktioniert hat und auch
nicht funktionieren konnte auf jeden
Fall gelang es den Kommandeuren der
regulären mittlerweile bei Putin immer
mehr Zweifel an den militärischen
Fähigkeiten von brings zu sehen
daraufhin wurde ihnen das Privileg
entzogen neue Häftlinge ausgefängnissen
zu rekrutieren und auch die Waffen
Transfers der Armee an die Söldner
sollen eingeschränkt worden sein so
berichtete zumindest Bloomberg nun ja
vielleicht war der Grund dafür ja der
folgende
ifg-nieperigozian könnte seinen Einfluss
in den russischen Mainstream-Medien
nutzen um sich als Kandidat für die
nächsten Präsidentschaftswahlen 2024 zu
präsentieren ins eigene föderale
Nachrichtenagentur veröffentlicht ein
Interview dass er mit russischen
Journalisten führte darin schien er die
Art und Weise zu imitieren wie der
russische Präsident Wladimir Putin seine
choreografierten öffentlichen Treffen
sind entweder um Putin wahnsinnig zu
verspotten oder um zu viel anzudeuten
dass brigorien wie Putin russische
Präsident werden könnte dieses Interview
auch um seine früheren Argumente über
die Notwendigkeit russischen Kämpfern
eine Hardliner Ideologie einzuflösen zu
wiederholen und dem russischen
Verteidigungsministerium zu unterstellen
dass es der wagnergruppe absichtlich
Artilleriemunition vorenthält auch wenn
hier also das letzte Wort noch nicht
schon so sein scheint ist eines ganz
klar die Bedeutung die Pre Gosch ins
wagnergruppe in diesem Krieg zeitweise
erlangt hatte war für viele eine extrem
große Überraschung sowohl für die
Ukraine als auch für den besten und erst
recht für die reguläre russische Armee
lange sei es so aus als seien die
Musikanten die Sie sich gerne
verharmlosen nennen auf russische Seite
die einzigen die noch in der Lage sind
in der Ukraine Fortschritte zu erzielen
das hinterlässt gleichzeitig den
Eindruck eines Mannes an Koordination
Herr kämpfen die nicht alle für das
gleiche Ziel es scheint als würden in
der Ukraine drei verschiedene Armeen
miteinander konkurrieren um zu sehen wer
in Putins Augen das meiste Lob erntet
Punkten die regulären Streitkräfte von
Verteidigungsminister scheuburg oder mit
Allahs Beistand die ausny oder eben
prägossen privat Armee die wagnergruppe
während Kati darauf als Oberhaupt der
Teil Republik in mit seinen zumindest in
die russischen Armee Strukturen
integrierten Kämpfern immerhin
irgendeine legale Existenzgrundlage
vorweisen kann sieht es bei Gosch ins
Hardcore Musikantenstadl ganz anders aus
die private Militär Thema dafür steht
das russische Kürzel cwk hat einen
unklaren Rechtsstatus so steht es sogar
in der russischen Wikipedia das scheint
im heutigen Russland aber absolut
niemanden zu kümmern was ziemlich
bezeichnet ist nun ja auch uns sind im
Moment andere Fragen wichtiger als der
Rechtsstatus warum braucht der Kreml
überhaupt eine Privatarmee was macht
diese wagnergruppe eigentlich sonst noch
so und wer ist eigentlich pregorian und
wie viel Macht hat er in Putin Russland
heute werden wir hier auf Politik all
diese Fragen beantworten und zwar gleich
nach einem kurzen werbe Hinweis unseres
Tron Sponsors surfshark dennis surfshark
hat nicht nur das heutige Video möglich
gemacht nein es hat auch ein VPN im
Angebot das wirklich empfehlenswert und
vor allem sicher und vertrauenswürdig
ist so lockt es z.B selbstverständlich
keinerlei Verbindungsdaten mit natürlich
kein eindeutig private Network kurz VPN
einen nicht vor allem Gefahren man muss
nach wie vor unsichtbar halten lassen
und wissen was man tut aber es steht
hier für eine Werkzeug mit gleich
mehreren Vorteilen da zum einen
erschwertes in Kombination mit anderen
Vorkehrungen eure Aktion am besten
nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures könnt
ihr so eure Anonymität im Netz erhöhen
zum Beispiel mit dem integrierten clean
wird das alle unerwünschten Cookies und
Popups Blog weiterer Vorteil eines VPN
ist dass ihr so tun könnt als wäret ihr
an einem anderen Ort so könnt ihr zum
Beispiel auf Websites oder
Internetdienste zugreifen die in dem
Land in dem wir gerade seid nicht
verfügbar wären auch daheim oder im
Urlaub damit schlagt ihr Zensur und jur
blocking ein Schnäppchen Netflix und
anderes Training diese die ihre Inhalte
nur in den USA Anbieten von Europa oder
deutsches Internet fernsehen im Ausland
gucken mit kein Problem und das ist noch
lange nicht alles mit nur einem Surfer
kommt oder wirklich alle eure Endgeräte
im VPN registrieren Handys Notebooks
oder sogar euren Smart TV so und wenn
ihr den Rabattcode politik.de angeht
bekommt ihr Aufschlag auch noch einen
Rabatt in Höhe von 83% und obendrein die
ersten drei Monate gratis dazu den Link
zu diesem Angebot findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video also
nicht besorgt damit auch gleichzeitig
uns finanzieren die Arme das könnt ihr
übrigens auch direkt mit Hilfe der
Spenden links ebenfalls in die
Beschreibung gepackt haben wir sind euch
für jede Unterstützung damit hättet ihr
uns euch in Zukunft noch mehr und noch
bessere Videos zu liefern so und nun
wieder zu unseren Fragen welche Ziele
verfolgt der kleine überhaupt mit einer
privaten Streit macht wenn er doch eine
ganze Armee zur Verfügung hat welche
weiteren Aktivitäten verfolgt die
Partnergruppe und wer ist brigochen und
welchen Einfluss hat er in Putins
Russland all dies wollen wir beantworten
indem wir wie gewohnt zunächst einen
kurzen Blick in die Geschichte werfen
also aufgepasst
wozu so eine Privatarmee alles gut ist
die große Frage ist warum eine defacto
diktatur-virusland die Privatarmee eines
geschäftsmannsdet man hat ja schließlich
bereits eine eigene Armee zur Verfügung
und eigentlich werden Kriege ja
normalerweise von Staaten geführt und
nicht von Firmen welchen Sinn soll das
alles also machen nun Russland ist nicht
das einzige Land das auf privat Armeen
zurückgreift sollte der Trupps gab es
schon immer es gab sich schon zurzeit
Alexander des Großen aber so weit
brauchen wir gar nicht zurückzugehen
reden wir doch mal über den März 2014
als Russland die Halbinsel Creme
annektierte das geschah damals ganz
anders als man sich üblicherweise eine
Invasion vorstellt in der ukrainischen
Provinz am Schwarzen Meer tauchten
plötzlich sogenannte kleine grüne
Männchen auf manche nannten sie auch die
freundlichen Leute wortkar besetzen sie
Schlüsselposition und blockierten
ukrainische Militärstützpunkte es
handelte sich dabei mussoldaten ohne
Abzeichen oder irgendwelche Markierungen
der Kreml wollte uns glauben machen sie
sein schlichtweg Sympathisanten der
russischen Sache einheimische Zivilisten
die sich in einem military Shops
eingekleidet und sich irgendwie und
irgendwo Waffen beschafft hätten und
dann hätten sie sich eben noch ein
zufällig auf der Krim getroffen nun ja
im Prinzip konnte man sich schon damals
als russische Soldaten identifizieren da
sie ja vor allem Putins Interessen
dienten aber gut schließlich hat das
alles der aktuelle Krieg in der Ukraine
sowieso bestätigt oder vielleicht doch
nicht
[Musik]
heute zumindest geht man davon aus dass
die grünen Männchen eine Mischung aus
Kämpfern von Sondereinsatzkommandos
Agenten des russischen
Militärgeheimdienstes sowie Personal der
wagnergruppe waren es handelte sich also
nicht um reguläre Armeeeinheiten sondern
um eine Mischung aus speerspionen und
Sölden an
das ist der Hauptgrund warum immer mehr
Länder auch Privatarmeen zurückgreifen
es geht um die plausibel dahergekommene
bestreitbarkeit das heißt die Behörden
können eine staatliche Beteiligung an
den Aktion sollte immer Leuten erst
recht wenn es sich um besonders geheime
Aktionen handelt und das alles bringt
erhebliche rechtliche und politische
Vorteile für den Handelnden Staat
deswegen lief nach dem gleichen Schema
dann auch kurz nach den eigenen auf der
Krim auch die russische Vereinnahmung
des dornbas ab Putin bestritten mehrfach
das russische Truppen dort im Einsatz
sein ein paar Jahre später hatte es dann
übrigens doch mal beiläufig zugegeben
aber wenn damals die Operation der
Grünen Menschen nicht glatt gelaufen
wäre hätte der Kreml weiter versucht uns
zu erzählen dass man nichts damit zu tun
habe und dass diese Leute aus eigener
Initiative gehandelt hätten aber es hat
damals nun mal gut funktioniert und dank
der Tatsache dass die fast unblutlich
verlaufen nicht als kriegerische
Aggression angesehen wurde hatte Putin
praktisch einen Freifahrtschein und ihr
könnt Euch sicher noch alle daran
erinnern wo dann vier Jahre später also
2018 die Fußball Weltmeisterschaft
ausgetragen wurde
genau in der Russland als sei nichts
geschehen Privatarmeen sind also eine
sehr praktische Sache und einige von
euch werden vielleicht denken oh mann
jetzt hat der Neoliberalismus auch noch
die Welt ist Militärs erreicht mit
Schurken die sich an die Meistbietenden
Tyrannen der Welt verkaufen nee nee
sowas kommt auch in vermeintlich
anständigen Familien respektive starten
vor denn genauso wie Russland Partner
einsetzt haben auch die Vereinigten
Staaten die Söldner von Blackwater
eingesetzt wobei diese Privatarmee
inzwischen Akademie heißt wohl eine
schlagende Verbindung
erinnern wir uns im Irakkrieg nahm die
Busch Regierung die Dienste privater
Militärunternehmen wie Black wurde in
Anspruch um die us-militärpräsent
schnell zu erhöhen als ich die Lage
zuspitzte das Praktische an der Sache
war auch dass ich die Amigos von Busch
Jenny Rossfeld und Co ein paar Dollar
zur Seite legen konnten und natürlich
tun Berichte über angeblich Übergriffe
einige privater Sicherheitskräfte dazu
bei dass sie in der Öffentlichkeit als
unverantwortliches Söldner wahrgenommen
worden was zu einer kontroversen Debatte
über ihre Aufsicht und Mangel der
rechtschaffenpflicht führte
was die USA mit Blackwater im Irak und
in Afghanistan gemacht haben zeigt
unmittelbar einen weiteren großen
Vorteil dieser militärfärmen ihre
Flexibilität sowohl was die Finanzierung
angeht als auch ihre demokratische
Legitimation eine Privatarmee kannst du
jederzeit schnell eingesetzt werden
stellt euch mal vor ihr seid irgendwo
Staatschef und wollt eure nationale
Armee in einem fremden Land einsetzen
dann müsst ihr das alles wahrscheinlich
vom Parlament absegnen lassen und mit
guten Argumenten in der Öffentlichkeit
aufwerfen und all das hat einen
politischen Preis
[Musik]
Parteien könnten anfangen zu pokern und
deine Bürger könnten protestieren gut in
eine Demokratie spielt das alles
natürlich eine größere Rolle als in
einer Diktatur aber selbst wenn ein so
autoritärer Mann wie Putin seine
reguläre Armee im Ausland einsetzen
möchte muss der Kreml die Duma
informieren und sich das abnicken lassen
schickt er jedoch ein Privatunternehmen
muss Putin nur zum Telefonhörer greifen
und schon geht's los ein weiterer
nützlicher Aspekt zeigte sich ins Syrien
wo Russland sowohl mit seiner regulären
Armee als auch mit Kämpfern der
wagnergruppe der Armee von Assad unter
die Arme Begriff schaut euch mal diese
Nachricht aus dem Jahr 2018 an der Kreml
distanziert sich von Berichten über
getötete Söldner in Syrien in der eben
gezeigten Headline kommt alles zusammen
Flexibilität plausible bestreitbarkeit
und ein weiterer sehr wichtiger Vorteil
Verluste Zielen nicht eben wirklich wenn
sie nicht bei der regulären Armee
entstehen sondern bei einer privat Firma
viele von euch werden jetzt vielleicht
denken was redest du da ein toter ist
ein toter ja natürlich biologisch stimmt
das aber in den Augen der öffentlichen
Meinung ist das nicht dasselbe denn Geld
ein Soldat der us-marins ist das Weiße
Haus dafür verantwortlich stirbt jedoch
einen Blackwater Agent im Dienst war es
sorry ein bedauerlicher Betriebsunfall
ein weiterer Punkt der für private
Armeen spricht ist derselbe wie bei
jeder anderen staatlich privaten
Partnerschaft Subunternehmer versuchen
ja normalerweise am wettbewerbsfähigsten
zu sein um lukrative Staatsaufträge zu
erhalten im Fall private
Militärunternehmen ist es genau dasselbe
was ich damit meine
[Musik]
ein Beispiel vor dem Einmarsch in die
Ukraine war der durchschnittliche Soldat
der regulierten russischen Armee wohl
noch nie in einem realen Kampfeinsatz
gewesen einige wenige von ihnen waren
vielleicht mal ins höheren stationiert
und ein paar Offiziere haben 15 Jahre
zuvor den fünf Tage Krieg gegen Georgien
mitgemacht und 20 Jahre vorher die
Tschetschenien Krieg im Gegensatz dazu
haben sich viele der Profis von Wagen in
den letzten Jahren nach und nach durch
Syrien Libyen Mali oder die
Zentralafrikanische Republik gekämpft
[Musik]
damit sind wir bei einem weiteren
Vorteil von Privatarmeen ihre Mitglieder
haben in der Regel mehr Kampferfahrung
als eine regulärer Soldat zudem sind
viele Mitglieder der wagnergruppe als
ehemalige Angehörige der russischen
Armee auch Veteranen der Tschetschenien
kriege das alles sind gute Gründe warum
private Militärunternehmen weltweit und
insbesondere in Russland florieren wer
Leben eben in Zeiten in den plausibel
bestreitbarkeit fehlende
Rechenschaftspflicht größere
Flexibilität bei halb geheimen Missionen
und erfahrene Kämpfer einen großen
Vorteil darstellen okay das alles klang
jetzt irgendwie logisch nicht wahr aber
bei der ganzen Geschichte gibt es einen
kleinen Haken die russische Verfassung
verbietet die Bildung privater
bewaffnete Einheiten denn ihr könnt Euch
sicher ausmalen was in einem solchen
Riesenreich los wäre wenn jeder einfach
so seine eigene privat ach nie konnten
und betreiben könnte das heißt aber wir
müssen uns fragen wie hat eigentlich
Putin das russische Gesetz umgangen und
wer hat das konkret für ihn getan
schauen wir uns das noch mal genauer an
[Musik]
Putins Chefkoch
zu Beginn des letzten Jahrzehnts begann
der Russland sich für private
Militärunternehmen zu interessieren das
Problem ist dass das russische rechtssie
nunmal nicht zulässt und es sogar
strafbar ist als Söldner zu dienen
dennoch betonte setzt Putin die Vorteile
solcher Strukturen die Interessen des
Staates ohne dessen unmittelbare
Beteiligung wahrnehmen metriorgos in der
damalige stellvertretender
Ministerpräsident gab einen Hinweis
darauf was man vorhatte wir denken
darüber nach ob unser Geld in die
Finanzierung ausländische privater
militärischer Sicherheitsunternehmen
fließen wird oder ob wir die Möglichkeit
der Gründung solche Unternehmen in
Russland selbst in Betracht ziehen und
einen Schritt in diese Richtung
Unternehmen es stellte sich aber die
Frage wer in Russland gerade bereit ist
etwas definitiv
illegales zu tun die Putin umgebenden
Ziel und Wiki waren nicht dazu bereit
sie hatten zu viel zu verlieren es
brauchte also einen nützlichen Idioten
jemand der wirklich geldgierig ist und
zugleich wenig Angst hat das Gesetz zu
brechen und so jemanden gab es im Umfeld
von Putin darf ich vor stellen
ihreniorin
denn der hatte als junger Mann einen
Großteil der 1980er Jahre im Gefängnis
verbracht wegen schlichter
Straftatbestände wie Diebstahl Raub und
Betrug als er 1990 wieder auf freien Fuß
kam stürzte er sich ins eben legal
gewordene Unternehmertum auf einem Markt
in St Petersburg macht er einen Hot Dog
stand auf ich habe als erster in
Leningrad Hot Dogs verkauft den Senf
haben wir bei mir zu Hause in der Küche
angerührt da zählte Mama auch die
Einnahmen im Monat habe ich 1 000 $
verdient das waren Berge von Rubel und
Mama hatte mit den zählen alle Hände
voll zu tun der Übergang Russland zum
Kapitalismus bottrigger riesige
Möglichkeiten aus dem Imbissstand
entstand eine würstelbudenkette und
daraus als bald ein kleines
gastronomisches Imperium namens kommt
gott-gruppe mit einigen schicken
Restaurants und einem gleichnamigen
Catering Service eine besonders
glückliches Händchen hatte mit dem new
Island dem ersten feinen
Restaurantschiff das in St Petersburg
auf der never kreuzte und der Russland
neureicher Elite war es ein echter Hit
auch dem damals frisch gekühlten
Präsidenten Wladimir Putin gefiel
pregorian
außerordentlich er kannte den
Gastronomen noch aus den Zeiten als er
Petersburger Vize Gouverneur gewesen war
Anfang der 2000er Jahre bewirtete Putin
auf dem new Island
Gerard oder george w Bush wobei genau
genommen wurden sie alle ja von bewertet
auf diesem Foto des Kreml Pressedienste
sehen die in Dienst fertig hinter der
Putin stehen diese Nähe zum russischen
Präsidenten brachte den Spitznamen
Putins Koch ein
aber es ist ja das eine wenn du gekommen
Kaviar Kamtschatka Krabben und das
feinste organoff der Stadt aufwischen
kannst aber eine ganz andere wenn du
Anführer eines riesigen völkeres bist
warum also haben sich diese Wiki
ausgerechnet an eine Figur wie bringe
gewandt um eine russische Schatten Armee
aufzubauen nur die Antwort findet sich
bei der concord-gruppe und ihrem
Catering-Unternehmen dank der guten
Beziehungen des Chefs hatte sich dieses
schnell einen weitaus riesigen Markt
erschlossen das heißt nur kalte Buffets
auf Empfängen und dergleichen
anzurichten Concorde bekam die
Versorgung von Moskauer Schulkantinen
russischen Krankenhäusern und das ist
jetzt entscheidend vielen sehr vielen
armeekasernen zugesprochen das waren
gigantische Aufträge und als bald ging
es schon nicht mehr nur darum als quasi
Monopolist Russland Soldaten zu
verpflegen sondern auch um Reinigung und
Unterhalt der Kasernen und sogar um
Bauaufträge für das
Verteidigungsministerium dank dieser
eingespielten Kontakte hat dass sie
viele Militärdienstleister trikotin dann
also auch den Auftrag zur Gründung einer
Privatarmee bekommen das natürlich noch
nicht mehr offiziell und wann genau war
das nun das ist schwer zu sagen aber
Vorläufer Strukturen der heutigen
privaten Wagner waren bereits 2014 auf
der Krim und im separatistenkrieg in
Dornbach im Einsatz einer der
Kampfgruppen kommande dort war ein
Gewissheit und kennt der sich den
Kampfnamen Wagner zugelegt hatte
angeblich weil er ein starkes Fable für
das Dritte Reich und den wuchtigen
operngeschmack von dessen Führer hatte
davon ze im übrigen auch sein eigener
Körper der mit nazi-tattoos geradezu
übersät ist von Sigrun der Waffen SS bis
zum Reichsadler mit Hakenkreuz für seine
private Kampftruppe mit der er ab 2014
in der Ukraine auf russischer Seite
kämpfte ließ er stilecht Helme im
Wehrmacht Design besorgen und die Miete
das ganze dann auch in wagnergruppe um
2017 wurde Kind außerdem zum
Generaldirektor von Concorde ernannt
konkrete Hinweise auf den
Gründungszeitpunkt der Wagen der Gruppe
liefern auch öffentliche Geschäftsdaten
das Volumen der Dienstleistungen von
Unternehmen die sowohl mit Goschen als
auch dem russischen
Verteidigungsministerium verbunden sind
stieg von 11 Millionen Euro im Jahr 2014
plötzlich auf eine Milliarde im Jahr
das ist schon ein wirklich auffälliger
Unterschied der sich wohl auch nicht
dadurch erklären lässt dass brigochien
damals plötzlich angefangen hat den
russischen Truppen teuren Kaviar statt
der üblichen Buchweizen kurze zu
servieren es muss sich dabei wohl um
etwas ganz anderes gehandelt haben auch
befindet sich das Lager in dem die Wagen
der Gruppe trainiert auf einem Areal in
molkien bei krass nur da das Team
Verteidigungsministerium gehört die
Verbindungen des Krems zu Wagener sind
also offensichtlich die Silo Vicky
traten an trikotin heran um über ihn
eine Privatarmee zu finanzieren aber wie
wir gleich sehen werden bereitet Ihnen
diese Umstand gerade jetzt jede Menge
Probleme lass mich hier nur schnell noch
eine zweite Geschichte erzählen denn
unser spezieller Freund bringt euch in
hat zur gleichen Zeit noch eine zweite
Armee in putinsdiensten aufgebaut eine
tolle Armee richtig bekannt wurde sie
für ihre manipulationsbemühungen im
US-Präsidentschaftswahlkampf 2016 als
die tolle aus orino im Internet
Propaganda für Trump machten wie bei
Wagner hat Gregorian jahrelang
bestritten damit auch nur irgendetwas zu
tun zu haben er hat sogar reihenweise
Medien und Journalisten im Ausland
verklagt die das behaupteten erst vor
wenigen Monaten hat er definitiv
zugegeben dass er der Pate der
russischen troll-armee ist
ich war nie nur der finanzielle Internet
ich habe sie erfunden ich habe sie
geschaffen ich habe sie lange Zeit
geleitet sie wurde gegründet um den
russischen Informationsraum vor
röpelhafter aggressiver Propaganda mit
anti-russischen narrativ aus dem Westen
zu schützen ihr seht schon pregorian
fühlt sich frei zu sagen was er will
selbst wenn er damit Verbrechen
eingesteht und mal sehen vielleicht
findet sich auch so manche von
Schützlingen im Kommentarbereich unter
diesem Video kommt schon ihr könnt das
ruhig zugeben denn selbst euer Chef
fühlt sich frei zu sagen was er will
selbst wenn er damit Verbrechen
eingesteht erlaubt sich sogar die
russische Militärführung grob also
pöbeln etwa indem er sie beschuldigt
dass sie seine Truppe vor bachmut
absichtlich nicht genug Munition liefern
und nachdem er bezüglich dieser Vorwürfe
zurückgerudert war fängt an auch nur das
offizielle narrativ seines Putin in
Zweifel zu ziehen die vom Grimmel
ausgerufen Zertifizierung der Ukraine
seit Quatsch da überhaupt nichts von
irgendwelchen Nazis in der Ukraine
wissen ja da spricht wohl der was der
nazi-experte höchstpersönlich
schließlich stammt seinen sympathischer
regelsführer und gehen auch aus der
Ukraine und wenn er schon mal dabei war
zerstörte er auch noch eine zweite große
parole Putins er bezweifelt nämlich das
Russland in der Lage sei die Ukraine zu
entmilitarisieren wie ist das Ziel des
Kreml war denn dies würde die
Vernichtung der gesamten ukrainischen
Armee voraussetzen was er trotz aller
laufenden Bemühungen für unmöglich hält
schließlich aber ließ er es sich nicht
nehmen dem ganzen noch die Krone
aufzusetzen und zwar indem er auch jedem
kremlarrativ widersprach Russland würde
in der Ukraine gegen die NATO und den
ganzen Westen kämpfen
gegen wen wir kämpfen die NATO oder
gegen die Ukraine wir kämpfen
ausschließlich gegen die ukrainische
Armee gegen bestimmte Gruppen
psychopathisches Söldner denen es nur
darum geht Russen zu töten und gegen
jene die moralisch und geistig die
Ukraine unterstützen also um Freiwillige
die ukrainische Armee kämpft natürlich
mit großen Mengen von NATO Waffen ja
pregorian scheint absolut
unkontrollierbar geworden zu sein und
vielen in Russland flüster Mann an der
Spitze von Wagner schlichtweg Angst ein
das ist auch nicht verwunderlich wenn
man die Erfolgsbilanz seiner rund um den
Globus betrachtet deren Spezialität sind
grausame Folterungen und
außergerichtliche Hinrichtungen nicht
nur von Feinden sondern auch von dieser
Türen oder mutmaßlichen Verrätern und
obendrein Filmen sie sich dabei auch
noch auf Video aber dazu später mehr
kehren wir jetzt noch mal an unsere
Gedanken vom Anfang des Videos zurück
als der prinzipiell vom nutzen sollte er
Privatleben gesprochen haben denn wenn
man die Putin schon eine solche
Privatarmee zur Verfügung hat dann setzt
man sie als grundloser Staat natürlich
nicht nur im eigenen Hintergrund einen
diesen Fall also auf der Krim nein man
setzt sie weltweit ein russische
Söldener suchen nach Gold und sehen
Chaos in Zentralafrika die
Zentralafrikanische Republik ist seit
zehn Jahren in einen Bürgerkrieg
verwickelt ihr Präsident wandte sich an
die wagnergruppe um seine Truppen
auszubilden und seine persönliche
Sicherheit zu gewährleisten und im
Gegenzug Boote ihnen Rohstoffvorkommen
an derartige Deals gab es wohl noch mehr
aus Syrien es bekannt das Assad in
Söldnern ein Viertel der Ölfelder
versprach die sie den von den USA
unterstützten kurten entreißen sollten
wagnerkämpfer wurden auch im Sudan in
Libyen Mali muss am Weg und einigen
anderen Staaten im Kreml ist man darüber
hoch erfreut denn Wagner erhöht den
russischen Einfluss in ganz Afrika zum
Nachteil anderer Mächte wie zum Beispiel
Frankreich darüber wie Russland und
Wagner die französische macht den Afrika
zurückdrängen werden wir übrigens schon
bald ein eigenes Video drehen vergesst
also bitte nicht das Abo unbedingt mit
glücklichen um es nicht zu verpassen
denn eines ist klar so wie der russische
Einfluss in Afrika wächst wächst auch
ins Geschäft
gewöhnt euch schon mal einen
Schlagzeilen wie diese die russische
Söldner den afrikanischen
Diamantenhandel übernehmen Aufstieg war
so steil dass das auch in Russland
selbst Besorgnis auslöste vor allem bei
den vermeintlich so mächtigen Silikon
gegeben
vergesst nicht das pregorian als
Quereinsteiger nicht zu ihnen gehört und
in diesen Kreisen Misstrauen weckt denn
die silo-weg gesehen ihn nur als
ehemaligen Banditen der dann irgendwie
zum Oligarchen aufgestiegen ist ihre
Beziehungen zu Gregor Gene sind voller
Höhen und Tiefen und manchmal brechen
die Konflikte auch offen aus ein
wichtiges Indiz dafür ist eine Art
Machtkampf in und um St Petersburg also
der Stadt in der pregorians Aufstieg
begann die aber faktisch von den Silo
Wiki beherrscht wird bekanntlich wird St
Petersburg von einer Bande von Leuten
geführt die sich die Taschen vollstopfen
und ihr Wort nicht halten jetzt gehen
niedrigem sogar Anzeige erstattet gegen
die Stadtregierung von St Petersburg
kein Witz und zwar wegen Gründung einer
kriminellen Vereinigung und Korruption
dabei ist der dortige Gouverneur nicht
irgendwer sondern Alexander auf ein
Schützling von sergeihenko Putins rechte
Hand für die Innenpolitik aber bringt
sich schon seit Jahren mit den
Petersburger Behörden und lässt seine
Medienmaschine gegen den Gouverneur
Trommeln und im Gegenzug kickte die
Stadtregierung pregorien aus großen
lukrativen Bauprojekten der Konflikt
kann nur aus einem Grund entstanden sein
bringt ihn hat er Gloss im Wahlkampf
2019 aktiv unterstützt bringt
nahestehenden Medien arbeiteten für
Begriff und schlugen auf dessen Gegner
ein doch nach der Wahl bekam Gregor
schon offenbar nicht die Gelegenheit
Petersburger haushaltsgelder so um zu
Schichten wie er gehofft hatte
das Licht bregorian mitten in einer
Diktatur wie Russland solche
öffentlichen Schlagabtausche mit
staatlichen strukturelleisten kann es
durchaus eine Folge des Krieges in der
Ukraine denn Erfolge an der dortigen
Front bedeuten mehr Einfluss im Kremmen
aber sie bedeuten auch mehr Feinde und
die schauen wir uns jetzt genauer an
Hahnenkämpfe in schlangennest
mittlerweile wissen wir ja recht viel
über den Krieg vor allem über seine
Anfangsphase es ist offensichtlich dass
die Dinge nicht ganz so gelaufen sind
wie man es im Kreml geplant hatte
Russland versuchte Kief im alten Po
einzunehmen und scheiterte was also tat
Putin nun anderthalb Monate nach dem
Einmarsch in die Ukraine wandte er sich
an die wagnergruppe Putin kennt die
Erfolgsbilanz von Wagner in und
auswendig und weiß dass die
männererfahrungen aus 1000 Schlachten
mitbringen das Problem war allerdings
das Wagner damals keine so riesige
Truppe war dass sie aus dem Stegreif
einen solch großen Krieg hätte
herumreisen können Leute waren zwar
massiv Veteranen und früher abgelehnte
Bewerber an dabei lockte man mit für
russische Verhältnisse sehr übrigens
sollte doch trotz all dem fanden sich
nicht ausreichend Leute die bereit
gewesen wären in der Ukraine ihr Leben
zu riskieren zumindest nicht in dem
Umfang den ein Feldzug dieses Ausmaßes
nun mal erfordert aber angesichts der
ausbleibenden Erfolge der regulären
Armee gab Putin im Sommer 2022 freie
Hand Wagner bekam Erlaubnis im
Gefängnissen Sträflinge zu Tausenden zu
rekrutieren auch ganz harte Jungs
bevorzugt Mörder und Totschläger der die
lautete Strafe Erlass gegen Fronteinsatz
und keine Weg zurück
Bürger
hier
ist
Papa
young am Anfang des Videos haben wir die
russischen Streitkräfte als dreiköpfigen
Drachen charakterisiert zunächst ist da
die russische Armee die von Bilderbuch
Wiki geführt wird
[Musik]
Verteidigungsminister scheuger und
generalstaatschef der rassimo doch diese
Technokraten haben auf ganzer Linie
versagt dann wären da noch die
tschetschenischen kadirovc die zwar
martialische tiktok Videos aber keine
großen Siege präsentieren können die
großen Hoffnungen des Kremls das Ruder
herumzureißen und wieder die Initiative
übernehmen zu können lagen daher bei der
wagnergruppe die als einzige in den
letzten Monaten so etwas wie Erfolge
vorweisen konnte Meter für Meter hat sie
unter aberwitzigen Verlusten am
Frontabschnitt um die Stadt Bach Boden
gewonnen und die Ukraine zurückgedrängt
gregorien hat daraufhin nicht gezögert
seinen zölln an die Lorbeeren
aufzusetzen und ihn Militärführung offen
zu kritisieren hört selbst
[Musik]
es ist ganz offensichtlich dass diese
drei Köpfe der russischen Truppe um
Putins Anerkennung wird einfach der
russische Präsident bringt sich
wahrscheinlich hey solange sie sich
untereinander zanken machen sie mir
meinen Posten als oberster Chef nicht
streitig auf diese schlaue Weise bleiben
Sie auf der einen Seite motivierte um
Siege für Russland zu erringen und auf
der anderen wird keiner von ihnen stark
genug um mir selbst gefährlich zu werden
das heißt Putin hat sich selbst und
seinem gesamten Umfeld ein hochgradig
paradoxes System aufgebaut aus dem weder
er noch die anderen herauskommen ja sie
sollen zwar erfolgreich sein um auch
seinen Hund zu werden aber eben nicht zu
erfolgreich man muss ihnen beizeiten
wieder einen Schlag in die Magengrube
versetzen damit sie nicht vergessen wer
der wahre Boss ist und genau das
passiert ist schließlich auch brigoche
[Musik]
Russlands letzte zugegeben bescheidene
Erfolge im Ukraine krieging vorrangig
auf das Konto vorne Wagner erst die
Einnahme des bergbaustädchens Solidar
und lange Zeit sei es auch so aus als
würde das bedeuten größere bachmut der
nächste Triumph werden doch erstens
wurde daraus nichts und offensichtlich
ist den Kreml inzwischen brikosch ins
wachsender Einfluss auch nicht mehr
geheuer schon im Januar wurde sergeist
beginnt eine Wagner general als
Oberbefehlshaber für die Ukraine
abgesetzt an seiner Stelle übernahmen
generalstoffchef gerassimo auf ein
treuer Verbündeter von den Posten
außerdem erlaubte Kreml brigoche
inzwischen nicht mehr im Gefängnissen zu
rekrutieren das macht die Armee
inzwischen lieber selbst das Resultat
die vorübergehend auf 40 bis 50.000 Mann
Stärke geschätzte Partnergruppe blutet
aus wortwörtlich denn die ehrgeizige
Taktik mit schlecht ausgerüsteten und
neurodermitär ausgebildeten
Infanteristen in einer Welle nach der
anderen gegen die gut ausgebauten
Stellung der Ukraine anzurennen hat die
totenkopftruppe massiv dezimiert die
Felder vor bachmut sind mit den gleichen
übersät es wird davon gesprochen dass
bei Wagner vielleicht nur noch 6 bis
8000 Mann übrig sind
laut britischem Geheimdienst ist die
Hälfte aller russischen Häftlinge die
für den Kampf in der Ukraine rekrutiert
wurden wahrscheinlich getötet oder
verwundet worden das
os-verteidigungsministerium schätzte im
Dezember das Wagner zu diesem Zeitpunkt
etwa 40.000 Häftlinge und 10.000 Zöllner
in der Ukraine stationiert hatte die
Gruppe kämpft seit Monaten um die
ostukrainische Stadt bachmut die sich zu
einer der blutigsten oder am längsten
andauernden Schlachten des Krieges
entwickelt hat Kommandeure auf beiden
Seiten haben sie als Fleischwolf
bezeichnet im Februar wurde berichtet
das Wagner die Rekrutierung von heftigen
gestoppt hat da immer mehr sich
weigerten für selbstmordmissionen in der
Ukraine angeworben zu werden es wurde
auch berichtet dass die Gruppe nun auch
keine Genehmigung mehr hatte neue
Häftlinge zu rekrutieren stattdessen
sollen Wagner rekrutiere in Moskauer
Gymnasien erschienen sein und die Daten
von Schülern gesammelt haben die an
Kampf einsetzen interessiert waren
rikaschin fehlt nun der Nachschub an
frischen Kanonenfutter aus Russland
Knästen also sieht er sich einfach in
Schulen um übler hätte es sich auch ein
Mark nicht ausdenken können Olga Romanow
war Leiterin der Stiftung Russland
hinter Gittern sagt im Januar das von
den 50.000 ehemaligen Gefangenen die von
der wagnergruppe rekrutiert wurden nur
10.000 bei den Privaten
Militärunternehmen geblieben sein der
Rest sei entweder getötet oder verwundet
worden wird vermisst ist desertiert oder
hat sich ergeben und das bei Wagner eher
mordlos denn Soldaten ihre regiert hat
sich auch daran gezeigt wie man mit
eigenen Männern umgeht die sich haben
gefangen nehmen lassen
Hinrichtung eines der Gruppe Wagner mit
einem Vorschlaghammer Warnung an
Überläufer auf einem tellergren-account
der mit der wagnergruppe verbunden ist
wurde diese Woche ein Video gepostet das
zeigt wie der ehemalige Gefangene jetzt
gegen die Nutch mit einem
Vorschlaghammer erschlagen wird das
erschreckende Video richtete sich als
Soldaten die aus Gefängnissen und
andersrum Kampf in der Ukraine
eingezogen worden der Einsatz eines
Hammers als hinrichtungswerkzeug ist
etwas das von der Wagen eine Gruppe
bereits aus dem Syrien Konflikt bekannt
ist es ist ein Markenzeichen der
Partnergruppe auf die Frage nach einem
Kommentar zu dem ich eine richtungsvideo
sagte Wagner Gründer jetzt dass das
Video den Titel tragen sollte ein Hund
erhält den Tod eines Hundes es handelt
sich um eine Brutalisierung des Krieges
das alles erklärt auch die
Verbalattacken die pregorian in letzter
Zeit gegen die russische Regierung und
die Silo Wiki ablässt er sieht seine
Position bei Putin in Gefahr seine
Truppe und seine eigene Existenz wohl
auch inzwischen bettelt er in Russland
gerade zum Beistand und jammerte vor
paar Mut laufe Wagner Gefahr von den
Ukrainern und Single zu werden wenn sie
nicht verstärkung erhielten die extrem
lernfähigen Streitkräfte der Ukraine
haben sich nämlich an seine brachial
Taktik angepasst und die für sie
günstigen verlustquoten bis zum Anschlag
ausgenutzt und zwar um ihrerseits eine
ebenfalls brachiale abnutzungstaktik zu
fahren eine Taktik die Wagner rein
arithmetisch nicht durchhalten kann aber
darüber haben wir bereits in unserem
letzten Video berichtet die Bewertung
der wagnerischen Mission in der Ukraine
aus militärischer Sicht fällt den auch
sowohl Wahl als auch real vernichtend
aus um im Kampf gegen eine Armee
bestehen zu können die Waffen und
aufklärungstechnisch sowie taktisch auf
den Niveau des 21 jahrhunderts agiert
ist nun mal mehr nötig als Horden von
Infanteristen in endlosen Wellen in den
Tod zu schicken denn die Durchführung
einer erfolgreichen Offensive mit
kombinierten Waffen und Truppengattungen
erfordert die Beherrschung komplexe
Operationen und die Koordination der
Einheiten verschiedene Verbände auf
höchstem Niveau ob Aufklärung Logistik
Söldner reguläre Truppen oder
Eliteeinheiten bei den Russen herrscht
jedoch aufgrund der bewusst durch das
Regime erzeugten spannungs- und
Konkurrenzsituation das reinste Chaos
wieder die Kommunikation auf der
Führungsebene noch zwischen
Unteroffizieren funktioniert so wie auf
ukrainischer Seite das beweisen immer
wieder sowohl ab hörprotokolle als auch
die bitteren Resultate auf dem
Schlachtfeld denn für optimale
Kommunikation und Koordination ist vor
allem eines notwendig gegenseitiges
Vertrauen und das ist in Putins Schweine
System eben ganz bewusst eine Fremdwort
und da hierbei schon rein systemisch
auch keinerlei aus nicht auf Besserung
besteht werden sich die Siegchancen
sowohl Wagners als auch andere russische
Verbände gegenüber den Ukrainern auf
weiterhin niedrigen Niveau bewegen die
Verluste werden hoch bleiben und die
Gewinne bescheiden und da haben wir
Bereiche wie die überlegene Aufklärung
und das Hochfahren des westlichen
rüstungspotentials noch nicht mal
angeschnitten ja es stimmt dass beide
Kriegsparteien viele erfahrene Soldaten
und Material verloren haben im Falle der
Ukraine besteht jedoch die Hoffnung dass
die Verluste nach und nach durch bessere
Ausrüstung und erstklassige Ausbildung
durch die westlichen Verbündeten
ausgeglichen werden russland hat diese
Hoffnung nicht aus diesem Grund setzte
man auf eine ganz andere Lösung fein
säuberlich im neuen taktischen Handbuch
beschrieben es handelte sich um einen
weiteren Versuch grassimos gescheiterte
Doktrin aus taktischen
bataillierungsgruppen kurz BTS zu
ersetzen da sich die Ukraine auf deren
Taktik eingestellt hatten mussten die
russischen Streitkräfte schnell zu einer
anderen Art der Armeeführung übergehen
mangels Alternativen gingen sie zunächst
zur alten sowjetischen Divisionen
Doktrin über doch auch diese konnten die
Ukraine schnell durchschauen und
entsprechend Kontern also folgte nun der
dritte Versuch der als die wagnerischen
menschlichen Wellen zweifelhafte
Berühmtheit erlangte im Allgemeinen
handelt es sich um eine Sequenz von
Vorstößen in kleineren infanteriegruppen
unterstützt von Artillerie Mörsern aber
vielleicht auch Maschinengewehrfeuer
oder Panzern und gepanzerten Fahrzeugen
hinter den Einheiten im Allgemeinen
handelt es sich um eine Sequenz von
Vorstößen in kleineren infanteriegruppen
die in Erwachsenen und bebauten Gelände
besonders effektiv sind also an Orten an
denen die ukrainischen Truppen sehr oft
Verteidigungspositionen aufbauen
allerdings besteht die ganze Einheit aus
mehreren hundert Mann aufklärere
Artillerie schützen drohnenoperatoren
und Drohnen Abwehr aber im Gegensatz zu
den BGs bauen diese Gruppen viel stärker
auf Infanterie bis zu 400 Mann auf drei
Panzer statt 200 Mann auf zehn Panzer
das ganze unterstützt durch 12V Spitzen
und weitere Mörser jeder Angriff
verläuft dabei nach folgenden Muster
Aufklärung der feinposition Artillerie
Beschuss damit der Feind in umgehen muss
und dann binnen weniger als einer Minute
der mit Panzerfäusten Granatwerfern und
Flammenwerfern schwer bewaffnete
Stoßtrupp diese Einheiten sind für den
Kampf in einem relativ kleinen Umkreis
ausgelegt sie sind nicht in der Lage
mechanisierte Manöver durchzuführen ihre
Aufgabe ist in erster Linie die
feindlichen Stellungen zu vernichten
nicht aber neue Stellungen einzunehmen
oder gar zu verteidigen dafür sind sie
weder ausgerüstet doch aufgestellt und
an dieser Stelle wird eventuell der ein
oder andere geschichtlich bewanderte
aufhorchen denn diese Taktik ist alles
andere als neu erinnert sie doch stark
an die berühmten deutschen Stoßtruppen
aus dem ersten Weltkrieg das Problem ist
allerdings dass diese verlustreiche
Taktik schon damals zu keinen
langanhaltenden Erfolgen führte die
Abhängigkeit von reiner menschlicher
Muskelkraft entpuppte sich selbst nach
erfolgreicher Einnahme der feindlichen
Stellungen immer als große Schwäche wenn
er Russland diese Taktik also wirklich
sinnvoll nutzen wollte um den Krieg zu
gewinnen müsste es auch über effektive
gepanzerte Einheiten und ein viel
robuste und effizientere log verfügen so
dass sie die entstehenden Lücken in der
Verteidigung ausnutzen könnten um tiefer
ins gegnerische Gebiet einzutringen und
daher gelang es den ukrainischen
Verteidigern immer wieder die
Wirksamkeit der neuen Taktik nach
anfänglichen Erfolgen zu absorbieren
russland steht also wieder ohne eine
funktionierende taktische Doktrin dar
laut iSd benutzt Putin bachmut um die
wagnergruppe zu zerstören und ihren Chef
in seine Schranken zu weisen analysten
zufolge ist der Kampf in der Ukraine bei
dem die russische Seite schwerer
Verluste erlitten hat Teil eines
größeren Machtspiels des Krems nach
einer voreiligen siegeserklärung des
Wagner Chefs erklärte der oberste
Militärkommandant der Ukraine dass die
ukrainische Streitkräfte die russischen
Truppen zurückdrängen und diese nun in
der Defensive sein fünf Tage nachdem
öffentlich davor gewarnt hatte dass die
von seinem Kämpfern erzielten Erfolge
durch Munitionsmangel zu nicht gemacht
werden könnten schnitt ihn Putin die
Versorgung ab alle Wege zum Kreml wurden
für ihn blockiert allerdings sei auch
das russische konventionelle Militär
praktisch besiegt alle wichtigen
Kampfeinheiten hätten im vergangenen
Jahr in der Ukraine gekämpft
unterschiedlich hohe Verluste erlitten
und mussten sich neu formulieren wir
sehen junge Offiziere die aufgefordert
werden höhere militärische Ränge zu
befehligen als in die sie
realistischerweise befördert werden
sollten es sind so viele russische
Offiziere im Einsatz gefallen dass die
personellen Ressourcen ausgehen und es
eine Generation dauern wird das
russische offizierchor wieder aufzubauen
warten wir also ab was in den nächsten
Monaten passieren wird was werden der
Rassismus von brinkosch in wohl noch zu
hören bekommen wenn seine private Armee
tatsächlich aufgereben wird und
plötzlich statt Putins Feldherr wieder
bestenfalls dessen Koch ist dann liegt
die volle Verantwortung für den Ukraine
Kriege wieder bei den regulären
Streitkräften können diese ihr aber
gerecht werden was wird brigochen als
nächstes tun sollte er doch der einzige
bleiben der den ein oder anderen Sieg
für Russland erringen konnte wird er
sich lieber aus der Ukraine zurückziehen
und stattdessen lieber Putins
militärische Ambitionen in Afrika
Puschen oder wird er vielleicht seine
eigene politische Agenda in Russland
fahren mit all dem werden wir uns
ausführlichst in künftigen Videos
auseinandersetzen also vergesst nicht
das Abo und unbedingt auch das Glöckchen
um sie nicht zu verpassen und wenn ihr
das erledigt habt sind die Fragen erst
einmal an euch gerichtet glaubt ihr dass
die wagnergruppe für den Ausgang des
Krieges noch entscheidend sein wird
könnte einer wie brigoschi vielleicht
sogar zu Putins Nachfolger werden oder
wird der blutrünstige Söldner Chef von
seiner Nebenbuhlern gerade eiskalt
abserviert hinterlasst bitte eure
Antworten in den Kommentaren und wie
immer wenn ihr das Video interessant
findet gebt ihm ein Like teilen und
diskutiert mit ihnen darüber natürlich
freuen uns auch jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]